the collective western declared a total
hybrid war and
it is difficult to predict
how long all this will last, but it is clear that the
consequences will be felt by everyone, without
exception, we did everything to avoid a
direct clash on 1 challenge, of
course, we accept sanctions, we are no
strangers to them in one form or another, they were
almost
always, Western politicians, of course,
need to understand that their attempts to isolate
our country are doomed, many experts already
admit this, so far, though quietly on the
sidelines, because it’s not politically correct to say it out loud,
but
it happens, well, outside the West, the
understanding is confirmed that the world
is becoming more and more diverse because of
this  nowhere to hide